lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es un
montón de desigualdades muy sencillas y
realmente lo valioso de que haga esto yo
yo creo que será justamente introducirte
a la anotación de las desigualdades así
que vamos a empezar con una digamos por
ejemplo que tengo la desigualdad x menos
5 menor que 35 entonces lo que me está
diciendo esta expresión es que necesito
necesitamos encontrar todos los posibles
valores de x todos los posibles valores
que sean números reales
que satisfacen que siempre que le
restemos 5 a ese número sea más chico
que 35 y por ejemplo puedes pensar en el
en el 0 que si le restamos 5 pues nos da
menos 5 y por supuesto que es menor que
35 verdad o puedes pensar en en menos 10
que si le restamos menos 5 tendremos
menos 15 y es menor que 35 o puedes
pensar incluso en el 20 que si le
restamos 5 nos da 15 y también es menor
que 35 entonces puedes notar de estas
observaciones que a diferencia de las
ecuaciones que hemos visto hasta ahorita
las desigualdades en realidad tienen uno
donde soluciones tienen muchísimas
soluciones verdad bueno ya después
veremos algunas ecuaciones que no tienen
una única solución si no pueden tener
varias pero hasta hasta ahorita donde
las las hemos visto siempre tienen una
única solución aquí las desigualdades no
tienen muchísimas muchísimas soluciones
y la idea es encontrar todo el conjunto
solución a esta desigualdad es decir
todos los x que satisfacen esta
propiedad y una forma de hacerlo y que
es de hecho muy parecido a lo que
trabajamos con las ecuaciones es quitar
digamos despejar la x de todos los demás
por ejemplo aquí podremos trabajar igual
que en las ecuaciones que tal si sumamos
de ambos lados un 5 sumamos 5 de ambos
lados y esto realmente lo podemos hacer
porque pensemos que si dos números están
desbalanceados es decir que no son
iguales pues al sumarle es la misma
cantidad seguirán estando desbalanceados
verdad piénsalo justo como en una
balanza que no está igual si le pones la
misma cantidad
desiguales verdad entonces si nosotros
sumamos cinco de ambos lados nos podemos
fijar que este cinco con el menos cinco
se anulan y del lado izquierdo me queda
sólo x y x tiene que ser menor que 35 5
que son 40 ok entonces este es mi
conjunto solución de esta desigualdad
son aquellos números que sean más chicos
que 40 y no pueden ser iguales es decir
todos los x menores que 40 así que vamos
a dibujar una línea real una línea real
ok para ver cómo se ven la solución de
esta de esta de esta desigualdad por
ejemplo aquí tendremos el 40 quizás
sacan del 41 quizás acá del 42
acan dará el 39 el 38 qué sé yo y así
nos seguimos 38 y así nos seguimos hacia
la izquierda y a la derecha
entonces me está diciendo que la
solución está dada por todos los números
que sean
más chicos que 40 es decir si lo
queremos graficar aquí tenemos el 40 y
son todos estos que están a su izquierda
muy bien todos estos ahora porque
circule el 40
yo debería rellenarlo sí sí sí el 40
fuera solución pero en realidad estamos
excluyendo el 40 el 40 no es solución
porque fíjense muy bien 40 menos 5 son
35 y no es cierto que 35 sea más chico
que 35 es exactamente igual verdad
entonces el 40 no es parte de nuestra
solución y por eso lo dejamos con una
bolita abierta y de hecho cualquier
número más chico que 40 tan cercano al
40 como quieras por ejemplo el 39.9 9999
todos los nueves que quieras siempre va
a estar en el conjunto solución verdad
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo digamos que
tengo la ecuación la desigualdad más
bien vamos a hacerlo acá x más 15 es
mayor o igual que menos 60
entonces vamos a notar aquí que ya
cambiamos el signo de la desigualdad
ahora estamos diciendo que este número
es más grande o puede ser también igual
que menos 60 entonces vamos a proceder
como lo hicimos en el ejercicio anterior
vamos a sumar algo de ambos lados por
ejemplo podemos sumar menos 15 y de
hecho lo voy a poner digamos acá bajito
entonces sumamos menos 15 de ambos lados
que me queda del lado izquierdo pues 15
menos 15 se anulan y sólo me queda x
verdad sólo me queda x y esto va a ser
mayor o igual que menos 60 menos 15 que
eso son menos 75 ok entonces como cómo
se vería aquí la solución
tenemos oops lo hice un poco sueco
tenemos aquí nuestra recta de números
nuevamente ok colocamos por aquí el
menos 75 digamos que este es menos 75
acan dará menos 76 menos 74 va pa acá
menos 73 y así sucesivamente verdad
hacia adelante y hacia atrás y entonces
nos tomamos todos los x que sean más
grandes o iguales que menos 75 entonces
aquí nos podemos tomar también el menos
75 y se puede también ser igual a menos
75 en el caso anterior no podía ser
igual y después nos tomamos todos los
que sean más grandes que ese todos estos
entonces así es como se ve mi conjunto
solución que fue lo que obtuvimos que si
yo tenía esta expresión de desigualdad
al sumarle menos 15 llegamos justo a la
solución que queríamos obtener y la gran
diferencia aquí es que rellenamos el
menos 75 y de hecho es lo ponemos así
una bolita
y evita porque si es una solución x
puede ser a lo mejor muy grande por
ejemplo puede ser un millón tres
millones 745 mil qué sé yo
todos esos son soluciones vámonos con
otro ejemplo digamos uno un poquito más
sencillo digamos que tenemos x menos dos
menor o igual que uno y vamos a proceder
exactamente de la misma forma por
ejemplo para cancelar este menos dos
pues le sumamos dos de ambos lados y qué
es lo que obtenemos del lado izquierdo
esto se cancelan y tenemos x menor o
igual que uno más 2 que es 3 muy bien y
entonces esto ya se empieza a volver
algo muy sencillo de de trabajar
volvemos a hacer nuestra línea de
números
la línea de números sueca pero la línea
final de cuentas por ejemplo aquí andar
el cero el 1 el 2 el 3 quizás hasta
ponemos el 4 a canda del menos 1 - 2 - 3
y me dice que la solución o el conjunto
solución de esto es todos los más chicos
o iguales que 3 entonces podemos
tomarnos por ejemplo nos tomamos desde 3
porque el 3 y lo podemos incluir y nos
vamos toda la izquierda todos los más
chicos o iguales que 3 y esta es la
solución lo puedes verificar tú mismo
por ejemplo cuando x es 3 tenemos tres
menos 2 que es uno y si si cumple por
ejemplo si x es cero tenemos cero menos
dos es menos 2 que también es menor o
igual que 1 y así puedes tomarte varios
ejemplos vamos a hacer un último de
estos por ejemplo x menos 32 es menor o
igual que 0 ok entonces como quitamos el
32 pues sumamos 32 de ambos lados
232 y qué es lo que obtenemos que x
estos se cancelan es menor o igual que
32 entonces si pintamos aquí mi recta de
números nuevamente por ejemplo que aquí
anda el 32 el 31 el 30 entonces
nos tomamos todos los que son menores o
iguales podemos incluir el 32 y todos
los que están a la izquierda y así es
como se de la solución y recordemos
siempre rellenamos cuando podemos
incluir este número en la solución aquí
no lo podíamos incluir verdad no hay
esta posibilidad de que sea igual por lo
tanto en este ejemplo el 40 no era parte
de la solución